conduciendo lejos de mí con life las
tierras de cultivo del sur del país se
pueden ver desde la carretera
ahora transformadas en campos de batalla
los misiles están enterrados en el suelo
mientras que los restos de los
helicópteros rusos ensucian los campos
en general los combates han dificultado
el trabajo de los agricultores
ucranianos los rusos no paraban de
disparar constantemente disparaban era
terrible si bien este campo de trigo fue
plantado el mes de noviembre no es el
caso de las demás parcelas que aún no
han sido sembradas donde todavía tenemos
que plantar otros campos como los
girasoles con máquinas y eso se hace
entre el 15 y el 20 de abril para ello
necesitamos combustible y semillas sin
embargo la gasolina está racionada en
ucrania y aquí
los tanques de combustibles están vacíos
ucrania es el quinto exportador mundial
de trigo aquí están las principales
regiones agrícolas del país muchas de
las cuales se ven afectadas actualmente
por los combates en curso por esta razón
el gobierno ucraniano espera que la
producción de trigo caiga un 30% este
año y ese no es el único problema
estos son los silos de grano del puerto
de mico life donde se exporta gran parte
del trigo del país nadie a ivanova tiene
trigo cosechado del año pasado
almacenado aquí pero no puede venderlo
porque el puerto está completamente
cerrado
debido a la guerra ya no tenemos acceso
al mar negro los barcos de la armada
rusa bloquean las entradas y salidas es
muy arriesgado desde el comienzo de la
guerra los precios de trigo han
aumentado un 70% lo que hace temer la
escasez de alimentos en algunas partes
del mundo